do you remember the quote to infinity
and beyond well how can you go beyond
infinity and what's the opposite of
infinity I'm about to jump in an
elevator and find out I hear you're
going to try and teach me some maths and
I'm not the best with numbers so I think
you might have your work cut out for you
everyone's great with numbers they just
don't realize they're good with numbers
yet oh no one's talked to them about
numbers in a way that makes sense to
them don't disappoint me
let's go okay so what is infinity
okay so infinity as you said is this
concept that we use to describe
something that doesn't have a bound
right so if we think of the natural
numbers which are just the counting
numbers like 1 2 3 4 5 etc it's
something bigger than that sound truly
so it's not actually a number but it's
something that's a number cancer can
tend towards so now right nothing ever
reaches infinity it just can get closer
to infinity so how is infinity useful to
us so I mean for me I work with lots of
different systems that change with time
so I like to look at what happens to
something as time moves into the future
right so if I have like a pond of fish
and I wanna know like what is is there
something that's gonna limit that
population of fish so maybe it's not
food not enough space so I want to look
at what happens in the future like do I
pick 5 years in the future do I pick 10
years in the future it's all kind of
arbitrary if I look but what happens in
that system as T tends to infinity yeah
then I'm gonna see maybe some kind of
limiting behavior like the fish is going
to reach a population it's gonna blow up
whatever so use it to describe something
ok so it sets the point so far that it
always allows you to find the limit yeah
exactly yeah
what's the opposite of infinity so in it
depends if I'm talking about infinity as
a concept of being unbounded the
opposite would be something that's
finite if I'm still getting time into
the future it will be time in the past
it depends on what it is using affinity
right yeah sure and so you know be an
infinite amount of time in the past but
then if I put something like infinitely
big it would be something
infinitesimally small so think about let
me just do that use my half way up
through and I have a lot of questions
about infinitesimally small yeah it's
not a great way to say no it's not and
it's not a great concept to think about
if I'm being honest because how can
something be infinitesimally small okay
so actually in reality like it's quite
hard for it to be but mathematically
it's very easy to be so if I I've got
like a radioactive substance and I'm
talking about its half-life so the
amount of time it takes for the quantity
of radioactive substance to have yeah
right so after one half-life that will
have after another 100 hobb and it will
have and it will have in it half so it
never actually reached zero because I'm
still having something that's not zero
it's just like so many decimal places
yeah yeah but in reality like eventually
you're gonna get to that loss like
Ataman it's gonna decay there'll be
nothing there yes sorry that's sort of
mathematically something can be
infinitesimally small in reality look at
you sort of do hits it would we ever go
that far or is it just so that we don't
have a limit on things and we can kind
of find the limit yes oh it's more it's
the mathematical equations that give you
this behavior as time goes to infinity
but in reality like there's the smallest
kind of subatomic particle we can't get
smaller so infinities kind of like a
tool to let us define the limits it's a
tool it's exactly that's exactly it it's
a really big tool really oh really
really tiny - yeah awesome I think yeah
thank you no worries
yes when you think about it Infinity's a
term that gets used casually quite a lot
and that starts to kind of dilute what
it means to us and we don't think about
it as deeply so it's really interesting
to kind of deep dive into what infinity
actually means and to realize that as
humans we're used to applying our
physical understanding of the world on
to pretty much everything so when you do
that and you say infinity is something
that means that there is no bounds it
kind of doesn't make sense we don't
understand how that can be because
there's always physical bounds but when
you reframe it as a mathematical concept
or at all it makes a lot of sense it's
something that we can use to find those
physical limits thatwe used to and I
really like knowing that it's cool to be
able to reframe and realize that I think
of things in terms of human physicality
when that doesn't always need to apply
you know infinity is just kind of a way
of life
[Music]
if you want to see more stuff from us we
will have a video for you next week you
can hit the subscribe button so you know
when that is already for you if you have
an idea that you would love explained to
you also pop that in the comments below
and I will go find an expert who can
explain it to me
so that I can explain it back to you see
you next time